(applaudissements)
- Le président de l'Assemblée
nationale n'avait pas prévu
annoncer ce vendredi
qu'il quitterait la politique
à la fin de son mandat.
Une annonce précipitée,
parce que le retour deBernard De
en politique avec la CAQ
vient de se confirmer.
François Legault évite
les questions sur son futur
candidat vedette.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Moi, ce que je souhaite, là,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on parle de
François Paradis. Puis pour ce
qui est des prochains candidats,
bien, on en parlera en temps
et lieu, en temps et lieu.
- Les partis d'opposition,
eux, s'empressent de critiquer
Bernard Drainville.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
parlementaire, Québec solidaire
- J'ai hâte de voir la grosseur
de la tasse de Kool-Aid qu'il va
boire pour vendre l'aspect
écologique du troisième lien
de François Legault.
- Parce que nos valeurs,
on y croit.
- Québec solidaire pense qu'en
recrutant le père de la charte
des valeurs du gouvernementvernt
de Pauline Marois,
Francois Legault se dirige plus
que jamais vers une campagne
électorale qui porterait
sur l'identité.
- Il veut que les questions
de l'urne soient la laicité
et l'immDonc,
le recrutement du père
de la charte des valeurs,
c'est tout à fait cohérent
avec cette stratégie-là.
- Le Parti québécois accuse
l'ancien ministre d'opportunisme
et doute de son intégrité.
s convaincu que le
public va se poser des questions
sur cette conversion tardive.
Est-ce que Bernard Drainville
passerait à la CAQ si la CA
n'était pas en avance
dans les sondages?
- Le Parti libéral, de son côté,
y voit la preuve qs
Legault veut ramener le Québec
vers le chemin de
l'indépendance.
MARC TANGUAY, dépu
LaFontaine
- Je pense que c'est son
Pierre-Karl Péladeau,
Bernard Drainville.Bernard Drais
en politique pour être
un chantre du Canada.
Bernard Drainville va chanter
la chanson que François Legault
a déjà entamée et entonnée sur
la gouvernance séparatiste.
- Mais les caquistes rappellent
que leur parti n'est pas
souverainiste.
MARGUERITE BLAIS, min. resp. des
Aînés et des Proches aidants, Qc
- M. Drainville, c'est
un politicien d'envergure,
voyez-vovoyez-vovoyez-vovoyez-v.
DONALD MARTEL, député,
CAQ, Nicolet-Bécancour
- On est un caucus très uni et
tout le le bienvenu.
- Mardi, Bernard Drainville
annoncera sa candidature pour la
CAQ dans Lévis. Il devra aussi
justifier son changement
d'allégeance politique:
d'un parti souverainiste
à un parti qui se dit
nationaliste à l'intérieur
du Canada.
Ici Pascal Poinlane,
Radio-Canada, Qué